so we've been running intensive holiday
classes using storybooks for 16 years
now the British Council in Paris and two
years ago we extended it to a 30 hour
course thanks to our partner school
networks using the partner school
premises these bilingual classes are for
children who have english as a first
language a second language a mother
tongue so they have english-speaking
parents they may have left in
english-speaking countries and a lot of
them have been educated perhaps in
english-speaking schools or
international sections etc these
children speak english fluently
spontaneously but they don't necessarily
have access to reading and writing so
the focus of the cause is actually
developing children's literacy skills or
understanding how the language works the
older children are actually helped in
writing sentences and little texts all
around the storybooks that they're
working on throughout the week the
younger children also worked through
phonics and start understanding the
spelling how spelling works in English
so the whole focus ease around reading
and writing but also developing
children's confidence in reading and
writing books some of them actually know
a lot more then they believe they do and
when they actually find themselves in a
classroom situation and they given the
opportunity of actually accessing the
language it's amazing how much they
learn how quickly they learn to
understand how English actually
functions
we write we speak and I love to play and
I love to do art I learned how to write
in English I learn how to read in
English
I practice my show then after we do a
bit of work and after the work when we
finish then we can read like little
books what's the first time she's come
and I feel that she's really gaining a
lot of confidence she's quite a shy
child but she seems to be really
enjoying and the other day I called her
in her bedroom a talking English to her
dollies trying to teach them like her
teacher has been teaching her here my
son is very enthusiastic about coming to
the British Council we practically run
here we come what's really benefit he
loves playing with the other children he
loves the fact that there's a lot of
variation which council does a lot of
different things during the day which
keeps them very enthusiastic and active
he loves learning the new songs and we
painstakingly here then he fit years
afterwards